[Musique]
c'est au domaine d'archambault à la
plaine des cafres qu'a été inauguré ce
vendredi 6 me la première boutique de
producteurs du territoire en magasin
tenu par les producteurs eux-mêmes dans
une ancienne maison créole sur un site
classé patrimoine architectural de notre
île
reconstruite à l'identique en 2019 elle
a été mise à disposition par le
département
le but c'est quoi le but c'est de rap
wasir et s'ils appuient entre les
producteurs et les consommateurs
comme ça parfois le bas les prix sont
élevés
les délais raccourcis les les circuits
et je suis heureux d avoir à faire avec
lucio qui se bat
chaque exposant tient à tour de rôle la
boutique leur permettant ainsi de
consacrer du temps à leur exploitation
et à la transformation de la produit il
ya huit producteurs qui sont présents
qui se relaient pour pouvoir tenir la
vente sur tous les jours donc on est
ouvert du mardi après midi au dimanche
et les jours fériés ça sera que le matin
donc les gens viennent faire leur
livraisons les acteurs se connaissent
entre eux et connaissent leurs produits
donc ils sont capables de faire la
promotion de chacun des producteurs
présents
l'objectif c'est donc de ne pas rajouter
de mars le magasin n'a pas de marge
c'est bien le promeut le prix du
producteur qui est en magasin et qui va
être totalement redistribuées du coup à
ce producteur une visibilité
supplémentaire pour ces producteurs mais
également le plaisir de s'adresser
directement aux consommateurs
ce que j'aime c'est
l'amateur en fait
expliqué comment je travaille comment
gens fonctionnent et puis il ya ce
relationnel qui se crée et c'est très
important c'est très important dans
les gens reviennent un petit peu de plus
en plus haut
à la production locale donc c'est
important d'avoir cette relation entre
intéressant pour faire connaître son
produit pour aller à circuler pour eux
aussi et bien au moins les gens puissent
profiter pour ce qui peut pas monter à
cilaos récupérer les projets un projet
évolutif puisque très prochainement
auront lieu des ateliers animés par les
agriculteurs eux mêmes en fonction de
leurs compétences
[Musique]